it should offer some cause for relief
wholesale gas prices are falling but the
withdrawal of government support means
that our bills will actually be going up
by an average of 20 percent
families like Carly's are wondering
where they're going to find the extra
cash
the single mom from South London said
that it has been a Lifeline the
combination of that sort of being
reduced at the same time that bills will
continue to go up and it it remains like
winter still and are still having to use
energy quite a lot of energy
um of course is yeah is worrying and and
quite stressful to think about what that
will mean off gem has lowered its price
cap because wholesale gas prices have
come down considerably since February
last year when Russia invaded Ukraine
the regulator factors this in when
setting its cap which limits the amount
energy companies can charge their
customers look at the black line here
you can see the cap is coming down in
April and yet households will see their
bills go up it seems counter-intuitive
but it makes sense when you look at the
blue line that's the energy price
guarantee the government's own cap which
has been subsidizing our energy bills
since October but from April that
support becomes less generous as the
government cap rises from 2500 pounds to
three thousand pounds it means our bills
will be going up because we will be
paying a bigger share of the total cost
hello Hi how are you campaigners are
calling on the government to maintain
its support for households at the
current level
the same goes for businesses with
industry bodies warning that there could
be a wave of company failures it's like
a cup of tea or a coffee Kate Ashwell
who owns a vintage shop in Bristol can
only afford to keep her shop open three
days a week I don't know yet exactly
what the bills are going to be
uncertainty in business is not good you
want to know what your outgoings are
going to be every month we used to pay
around about 70 pounds a month for our
energy and they've gone up to just shy
of 400 pounds a month
the numbers are staggering but the
chancellor maintains that he won't be
loosening the purse strings
for now Bill payers can only hope that a
warm spring awaits
go pretty no one Sky News